[Music]
[Applause]
Harriet first Ronis
[Applause]
Invictus gaming will hoist the
summoner's cop together
guys 2018 is over and what a year it was
for eSports now you probably forgot half
the [ __ ] that actually happened and to
be honest so did we that's why we've got
our interns hard at work collecting the
best clips from 2018 at the end of the
day it had nothing but nothing for this
best-of we're making our way back
through the Year month by month by month
no matter what eSports you're into
League of Legends csgo and everything in
between
we got you now that being said we
couldn't include literally every sick
clip from the year because this would be
like a four hour video and I'm just not
about it
so let's pour one out for the clips that
didn't make the video down let's see you
at the crossroads grandma now that we
got that out of the way 2018 started
with a bang of cloud nine becoming the
first ever North American team to win a
valve major at Boston we also had Penta
sports securing their spot as the best
rainbow succeeds roster in the game we
had an incredible spring split for
League of Legends dota 2 majors the
overwatch League you name it here's the
best of what happened January to April
in the second that's a great snap from
pads I'm going back towards the a sign
the full rotation is here but majors
almost already on the flank this big
this might force the hand of cloud nine
hours they've having to drop the player
three there though the space soldiers to
look to defeat this push there is the
peak there's the flash back very
important how comes Antares guess
nothing down to pass picks rush out the
air now another one from past what else
do i goodness pass for from him
absolutely under leave
then from him all like called the ACE to
take the match there we go that is Nico
coming in the back twice it's that
bridge day all of a sudden is flipped
around once again two versus one the
world's best player up against it the
stay in the game they'll go to the FIFA
Nico yes again we're going along time oh
my god there are chances here for face
guard is watching the cross too short
information they know say only confers
down straightaway that was picking the
only chance the Guardian comes back in
oh god idiot - there's still more to go
over that way must want upon the peaks
come in with Guardian will not stop one
more to go and Guardian get them all
towards thing nothing else is going on
he's gonna go back Stewie's on his own
but look at a time look at this
still around we go David I'm hardly
number its Guardian purpose to give me
280 can teach in this position before to
win phase around a very important very
crucial on Canada night cloud line we
saw from this position before you cannot
miss a single shot Guardian waits
patiently as cloud my scepter push up
[Applause]
any major champions
[Applause]
thank you no rocks because they just
can't find any soda final there's a
flash Infiniti wants to start this one
off with the nether grasp is actually
gonna be canceled it's I'm Trevor oh my
god the triple star massive kiba's strip
will kill quads right now is this gonna
be the Penta he's gonna be delivered at
this time driven in three years
pentakill pecan Everett doesn't die
somehow someway look now into the pit I
was gonna say fell to the pit here Oh
carpe gets the counter Saipan the baby
made a cream puff oh that that goes down
carpe totally going wild on this
Widowmaker right now oh do you look what
it looked like San Francisco it's such a
good opportunity but Hart Bay is joining
again all of the donut does go down to
Red's comes in from NY excel and here
comes mine gets one gets two looking for
a bit more it gets another one
are you kidding me this guy is gonna
single-handedly change the point back
over oh okay hi Big Boss line is on the
scene now New York only a couple percent
away can they hold it Houston needs to
make this fight happen right now they
need to grind it out and they're getting
the kills to do just that pie in a
little bit on his own here all but he
takes flack work out as he comes in
little ink sir
here's
Kari gets Fanny with the Deadeye and
there's another one fly that this guy is
unstoppable my excel takes well as
you're about to see with the emphasize
and nailed the shots not many
widow-makers would go for this play but
I'd would just absolutely nails it here
even fish eagle spit chipped and get it
later with the double infernal would you
stop outside of the Greek Hall hold on a
second copy finding the dog 24 seconds
electronic picking on one kill simple
there with the AWP taking down rain
first next in line is all of my stuff
but I can say it oh my god simple taking
down Guardian and Nico the last one left
now there's gonna be the slow C's down
there using the tarik ultimate they got
two and a half seconds to come up to the
base and it looks like it may just be
enough time but suddenly the fight is
starting to break out there looking for
a chance to print this one back Betsy's
in the middle of that everybody and he's
not gonna take it down quite yet sheriff
wants to redeem himself
selphie pushing in rouen gonna get down
it's grated part of this wants to bring
it home I don't know if a cat or you get
it made oh it's gonna add the game
Barger's wants to bring it into ruin
beautiful bouquet do the base defense
once again my goggles they see nothing
and they may not he gets away said scary
at the last second
fly by his Garin Mike young filling a
sore spot
licorice looking for one boob radio
Jake's good help solidify the kill
dodges the fracture Mike young back and
forth just biding his time but still
holding his breath because he is going a
down and Link even fix it an effort
might have found it pops up Jake I'm
gonna go ahead try to eat his way out of
there finger goes it for the Todd
justice punch connects in and Bishop
goes low and he's gonna die shower goes
golden but he'll get taken down but now
bang is into the back but he's isolated
himself he finishes up one may cats all
above treadmill cow flag are you kidding
me insane play from him again the
advantage to faze but again the ball
implanted cloud 9 can they do it three
times in a row suplex off with this time
make that one scoot off your turn you're
up and he's already got the first he
goes oh it's neat you in the smoke as
well he doesn't know it but he goes back
out he's oh my god close is that how bad
did you doodle and stomp connects on
just the lion but still able to get off
the hex Pasha throwing in the impetus
and there's the finger to finish him off
static storm kinetic field from toes you
just nodded off the mark
the more playing able to pull it back
and EDC in huge trouble
the right clicks will going to respawn
he diesel have to burn the vine back up
a burst up full here is Windham
magnetized rocks in town and they are
rolling through secret or on a mid 1/2
the shilling frame exits backup agency
modal Bud puppies the only one who's
dropping words the team secret please
don't live in the back lines I rented
con close the distance he'll be Farah
strikes up brain says back a foot of a
puppy so he can get mole alive as
aggressive jumps on down yet so talking
his tail the dental cleaning up your
losses here we got all these flash a
backline the pub big jump to the ice and
adherent a triple kill for him about to
make an ultra spinning his way through
its RF all struck kill for a we still
have to worry about exceed smiting this
they don't have fission just yet Olli is
trying to get some here bear at what
corner HP very very little that should
be wanting to go over the wall
[Applause]
some damage here to this one I don't
think you get away with this
he's gonna fight a little bit with the
shield on you buy some time he's gonna
do good at that but his health bar still
running low gets to get out you're
kidding me impact actually gets the
defendant she'll eat why are you
freaking kidding me in fact
and that is ridiculous
they've gotta try and get some work done
no Molotov to use as a smoke on the site
anyway foresters picked up ward can he
go any better than that he knows
Nazz bark gets pushed on he is very
wisely not getting into frankenz at Red
Bull kill Wilkie now at a 1vs1
he might have the yokai still but it's a
post plant situation and half of the
fuser has been whittled down SPARC is in
a perfect spot to clutch this right now
and he goes back in for their future
there's no time spark clutches it out in
a one versus four while the start of
2018 was pretty sick it was nothing
compared to the summer we had I mean
think about it we had oh gee lifting the
ages of Champions and what was
potentially the best TI ever and who
could forget the incredible evo we had
this summer plus plenty of csgo action
League of Legends rocket League Rainbow
six overwatch you name it so let's get
into it with the best of May to August
no 1 V 2 3 zip NYX incredible in these
situations but going through the
checklist mentally just is up there
Forster wait
zip miss gets the crunch bomb to be
planted now because work his way back
through he's got himself a nought is
this looking for
six needs to laughing beautiful short
one is good
the 1v3 needed from the God himself Nico
known for trillions and he needs to call
upon it right here right now device
towers in the corner the shot goes up
[Applause]
Dupree closing in Heath got the rifle as
well but Nico you know what he can do he
looks he waits here comes the hit yeah
that's what - you helped another Robson
a great call to this brazen head shots
in a row unbelievable and that's gonna
be over time why are you there
Fabien with a very easy kill and it's
gonna be up to BC to clutch yet again
the mirror playing inside a small office
they'll go for a c4 tosses it out run
hit BC this has to live for two seconds
get paint you fight him so evil geniuses
will stick the third round orange eat
inside the parapet shoot for me in
dollars bail we're gonna fight that's
already Achilles
it's gone Jaso to lose guerilla
attitudes in a fixed amount the feathers
are goes back and forth the show who
dies
please mercy keeps are in GLI kind of
ragnarok to try and escape the inhibitor
will fall middle they goes let me solve
it caught my part
[Applause]
so he comes through that show mine if he
has already killed I believe Nikko in
mistakes we solve one shot on the nickel
then he killed mistake no he comes
through the shots on the striker into
kelex first shot Nazis against then they
have the kill but here comes your
equipped with the clave down seven
people geniuses in a horrible horrible
scenario some else back up though is on
TV they have a regeneration maybe they
actually have a sustain the tooth is
damaged you have to type on TV stay in
his grunts and the beak a piece of the
glimpse rupture doesn't kill it but now
they charge after they're looking for
disrupt the bara strike from Tim create
small space and you have Raven I don't
know how he face to live through all of
this the photo bones have been killed
them off they get the back onto our now
Buell scepter did SK taking out in the
fight for half a second but he's got
blink pirates right off right now and he
goes deeper off the wall or I'm sending
Armel already has an ultra kill
maintainer rampage and they can get more
critical glimpse down again these
Olympics division think the
Thunderstrike oh no they turn four will
they give him the double you better tin
that is not yours to have this is not
your food Darren as is a double rampage
for our Bell they watch the cheer three
tower falls i channels they missed
anything
it's a five-year-old back wall epicenter
on top they kill to make it three
straight away this is the turn for
optics they have not lost and yet the
dark seer low breeze survives only
because of the E on disk but they get
obliterated be Russia absolutely coming
in at Stewie's the only one in there
and he's got an MP 9 he's gonna get
flashed in he's seen a so like that good
pick for Navi now sports already
achieved 50% back to that a minute
[Applause]
goodbye Oscar thank you for playing
today bring him back bring her back yet
Wow so badly what's the extra sparkly I
can't hate on that but at the same time
though I have a feeling he would want
the Ally or the extra help cause if you
get touched that's gotta be curtain
formaggio and it's low health for 100
thieves but they're gonna sort
themselves out and find the way back
into the oil Santorin after he does get
a good use out of that stop our meteos
is looking for that final kill though as
he hunts them down a few turret shots
through Cody Sun gun to go over get the
ad adaptive shield they keep himself
alive only just clips you buy that poco
2k plus the the IRISA ultimate as well
and they're just able to do it for
profit
what did he do with this here what was
this entire clips nuts honestly it won't
be five-star host best way to gain Julis
best way in the game by far our best
play of the match for sure Provident was
on fire so many different euros that he
canceled to bring out it was very
effective okay I like this with the
Gladius this is this is cheap either
trying to circle around fire what
interrupt is a little bit yeah where are
you going where are you going background
oh this is so nasty chum postilion small
so he's fighting you again sort of
walked out what I'll try to do is I
think he's gonna either and he's gonna
either switch to Widowmaker
[Applause]
[Applause]
the best-laid plans fail but not this
one down and Nick all the finally find
my keys Acadian look at a break back to
member the cloud nine further into optic
territory they want to get themselves
away from this the power of evil going
sevilla most people face is with the
blades but triple kill for optic kicks a
charm so looks like unreal the first
ones Baranof catches the ball fall
this is way too exciting working on a
birthday ever he didn't duck too high
block that sign up and they get his play
soccer play from JD CR or he gets it one
more he could do it oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay that is that is a definitely a
sequencing he has practiced and set up a
backlight Charl they're both with the B
reversal knocks them down
oh that should be punishable 2018 and
catching them with the sherry huh
throw it out Oh Oh
that's my boy
Oh
oh gee with the fortitude to stick
through it and beat anything with such a
boy
and note said the look-ins chasing down
ball to smash will connect from MSS the
best when you watch bring all those
sammich or goes to the juke no wait out
of it and the turn around almost there
with the right clicks he's picked up a
double kill strike it's the triple Sam
Sam H oh my lord
poppy the meteor hammer beat and a CSS
one buddy they do have an a no the chase
boards feel break they're gonna go down
Oh s4 he's thinking about it oh he wants
it so for black before they caught a
wall this summary on top of to be able
to break that one the supernova follow
up everybody's gone triple kill who for
sumail easy peasy as they all go down
plate be teased forward the ball is up
to Thompson please defend heck serve it
very visible you put a very very low
life piranhas but og they can't find the
target eggs Nerva
he's got the grip he's got the control
he's got the kill Thompson is done but
he ends up with the actors slam father
hasn't fallen
play Jarrett's the Savior Virgie final
hockey tip him up punch at the morva the
league ups fall instead go to control
hexler he'll go down this is the game
[Applause]
it goes to 3G how many times they've
they've reached the grand final good
arleigh of a major never T I fully load
uni that summers number two minutes then
get Thompson Thompson epidemic so Dianna
Anna can you do it here is it our best
shot
Oh Opie's lifetime three dead now on LGD
no buyback throw to the agent
gee
and friendship I've done in here ladies
and gentlemen you're champions
[Applause]
and it goes up for the left-hand-side
realm destroy Jacques HP for their sake
shotgun no fear rot can't get three
kills and they will turn back to Baron
Spotty's not close enough to stop this I
don't think so much secure there it is
the base comes in here four kills go to
Casey the triple kill force mad looks
like Ning is looking for a flank that's
the curtain call they're pinned into a
narrow corridor look at the damage and
it comes across in English for entry
they found [ __ ] sigh once again he goes
he lands the paddle star person finds
the lollipop AoE dump LMG plate up and
you'll just see all the utility from PC
will be dumped in today's this gets one
psycho is aware that there's one playing
on stairs and they will take out Neil
fighter plant going down somewhat
successfully but no aces seasoned ages
coming in can he get it to big kills
from aces he sees the Donna Hawthorne
aces oh my goodness in a one thing not
you know he's still got the diffuser to
work through Giulio will now watch
and who's gonna prevail on this fight a
sledge versus the maestro any Intel from
fnatic right now could possibly be going
but look at this one frag grenade
remaining from Julian he's priming it on
the diffuser he'll toss it out in Aces
will he live he'll get off the plan the
maestro will shoot away at the wall this
is a bad oh my god how does this happen
can you believe all of that happened in
2018 we're not even done this video yet
now kicking off the final segment of
this piece we have a straw list
cementing themselves as the dominant
roster in counter-strike
with their win at the London major
we also saw the fall of Korean dominance
across multiple eSports you had I G
lifting the summoner's Cup at Worlds you
had Sarah winning at Blizzcon and so
much more so here's the best of
September to December 2018 with a plush
pillows are the silk robes the slippers
the massage oil I kept trying to give
himself a gap and that's going to work
absolute wonders spots a second player
coming up the boiler as well they can do
this Oh is he gonna trade fast enough no
no he isn't
oh that's disgusting that is absolutely
disgusting something Sakura another
headshot to finish off the job it really
sabotage their own finances here liquid
still have a chance toe a lead out of
nowhere it's now a two buses one and
twist is certainly capable winning these
sort of rounds what will be planted but
he is so aggressive in he's my buddy
finally skill he's gotta reload oh it's
all falling apart twist isolating the
corner still making this work this will
be absolutely fantastic waters baby
that's the reason why the Scout here
could be quite strong if Seekers able to
get a couple connections Wow what an
earth was that James could you explain
that nope sorry he dies there this round
this is lost that Aichi is pumping that
everybody how is that how is this real
life
that is beautiful yeah that's the stuff
good mechanics let's say you train - he
doesn't quite get ready for Nico's
presence of Palace which is a little bit
late to be fair could have saved his
teammates had he gotten that killed a
little bit sooner walk is bent at back
he'd go still pulls off against somebody
and up the ladder down and again it's a
very awkward position for TT and Nico
just dominates him he's now gotten three
kills and one more to find fifteen
seconds is the bigger problem bomb down
in front of him and I Molotov will
certainly keep the defence away and hold
so that they can't quite see him pick up
the ball I thought Nico was gonna be
dead there I thought pecks Kurt would
repeat it Michael Nico is now gonna have
a bomb blow it down in the nick of time
and he could still pull this back this
is the mid round stuff we're talking
about it might not be team play this
time it's individual heroics what a shot
as he just destroys X curat that was a
great idea and we phase you have to
admire how much pressure they're keeping
on Australis at the moment oh my god
that's all that's left between a stylist
and the majors if not the high ground
with the C's there surely he's gonna get
taken out or does it get he could pick
up an AP this might not be over yet
there's no Hitler they've gotta go
simple the second one they have to keep
going they've got a charge forward he
misses the job flamie now if the
five-seven is baiting the pair of short
B is red touching the Bob already going
to peak holding it now and there is it
[Applause]
called the Danes plant going down
getting pinged over and over and over
again can retro pull it out last time he
was able to stick it where a stroke gets
the coach how do these things happen in
these matches
don't look down and just on the range of
that claim or to connect critical art
hardship you can just chip right here
let's see chip
yeah what do you have to know they
changed too early
yes Toki doe knows that everyone do that
find an opportunity looking for a way to
the back line but I'm set remains on
touch sadly Bane are gonna get cut down
immediately by reckless finds a bit of
time with the stopwatch upset now
looking for a little before noop ducks
does try to get
we watch the Penta but that's not gonna
let it get box are though very low
opportunity with the time nuke duck
looking for a way to the back line but
upset remains on time sadly bane are
gonna get cut down immediately by
reckless finds a bit of time with the
stopwatch upset now looking for a little
before
the Quadra that shaved his pubic hair so
close to a strong forgetting get a kill
James getting in the old case they're
gonna try they gonna dive into the pit
plenty of damage available but will they
even stop the Baron has the Spice Girls
a juggler it's Katy
looking up trying to stay in a fight if
they can the shine is made its way on
the inhibitor turret onto the Nexus
turrets they're gonna be taken down
Katie still marching it's a base raise
the size of the moon excess Katie's on
the red who's gonna win the shy will not
and Katie digs in the game for no
they're gonna fight another one though
and this one bodies then stops the cue
here come foul and as well to be one
proxxon may have bit off more than he
can chew the helpers running down the
kick you gorgeous
once again this might buy broccoli
incredible and you can see it stops the
damage of the second QPD Kosak francium
I think he surprises the IG jungler and
then just the ability to know that there
is no way out the only way is for dials
on him I mean the man had like 20 L that
he goes in for the flash kick he could
have looked so silly had he gone down
but he makes it happen
Jisoo K is going to be stopped by cube a
potentially but the inhibitors still
taken down and tasuke gets himself away
it's four before in this bottom part of
the map TP availab TVP going there
didn't even look at the big things
happen it's until it going into the base
vitality has to buy time that's the goal
Hubei has its gonna defend this on his
own juice Duquesne will not be shut down
and it that pushing mr. Umberto will
take them down it's an impossible
defense at this point
Roxann reckless versus the world
reckless goes on a rampage
but Ning is still there pressuring onto
the turret with the rest of IG reckless
is down Bronx's away I cheer on the
Nexus the LPL has never won before but
that will change today the crownless are
finally king and fitness gaming for year
2018 world champions
well feet I can show you that just I
just heard offensive to say just look at
offense today to the side cloud9
mounting an assault
switchy bounces to it
[Applause]
squishy cloud9
[Applause]
my majors should confirm the round this
point is tarek oh my goodness finding
all the headshots surely he doesn't have
a chance here he'll go for the plant
it's actually looking possible he'll get
it down here it's up to the device to
try deny everything
Tarek could win the one versus four he
has a model tome available to him device
is low and he has to wait for his
teammate he's got to start moving milk
because he doesn't have information
behind him he's expecting it to be from
the stairs but now that flash comes out
device trying to work back in is giving
away the fact that it become enough runs
[Applause]
so that was weighing a position on the
side but the Nimbus and boundary
striking down solos in trouble they jump
part they get the kill with a stun on
the side they've caught Nisha Nisha has
to double ganger into the pin and get
away
[Applause]
thank sit down secret in three nisha
so 500 doesn't grab the lid the roamers
on phases behalf Great Muta the double
Koga and yonas vanquished leaving Kanto
riccati to deal with the three remaining
members of phase and very quickly he
will reduce it to two with Maringa and
yuna just waiting put the shotgun of
moringa looking at the corner of the
doorway Kanto doesn't think he can vault
he sees the mirror for a second his
position in bathroom given away but he's
gonna give himself easy access in toward
service and this is a very winnable
position with that r4c in the hands of
the Finn I need to grab the defuser it's
quite a ways away and moringa prone with
the shotgun blast Kanto around the
corner almost connecting to maces he is
back on that foot 12 again there we go
fnatic closer and closer he's still on
the outside the elbow 12 we've seen
living through this on millennium what
do you this you lived in North America
right now absolutely shredding them neo
and what
take it away aces will drop it but not
enough to finish off the ash hasn't
received that healing that he's been
looking for quite yet a fun of my
[Applause]
fill the dragonblade nap crystal had to
hold that our road but it was going to
send it right back and now they can sit
on the high ground in the meantime of
course the payload is just moving
forward now China they're being stack it
out this is good for the offense Danny
in the back closer Trent's heads ideal
to use efficient out but ideally Jake
you'd like to save it as Canada now is
winding down this French defense Danny
absolutely free farming here on point
little three per baby gets a fart
gliding it up and celebrating that's
deserve it right there Betty looking
good great positioning in that team
fight as if Express to work back inside
of the lobby 25 HP only to work with as
the bomb will reach its logical
conclusion is he gonna go for this
are they still down there oh my god oh
my god oh my six clutch ministers got a
new sermon
unbelievable unbelievable from septics
he is the clutch master and that is
ungodly I'm sorry it's gotta go that way
north and a tick throw heavy uppercut a
half there not enough to kill made it oh
no the throw range from bison oh dear
Russell he saw the command throw after
he's got crossed up again well he's
gonna jump across them up in the
explosion if you would have got a
conversion from that out
but Jeb problem X moving on and winners
sighs good position here gets the throne
the X eclipse I'm trying to jump out not
enough to kill gotcha go got it that's
gonna do it e is your Capcom Cup 2018
champion Rachel's very own just got
signed this year gotcha cones gonna be
your Capcom Cup champion ladies and
gentlemen I plead on the side of JDC are
already on a ton
oh nice yeah well he'll sweet oh my god
you've never done that I help you
suppose not like this don't tell me he's
gonna bring it back again the blue stuff
is in too far oh oh my gosh yes I'm at
the wall to hope for
how many of those can we guess and
that's the big all he has to do is tap
down back and he could end food on
cisterna man look at this hardly any
left be careful of one more you get in
here maybe it look like they were about
to kiss birth sunny sports brought two
nights where our tech in one torch get
them in a mac-10 against AMA there's
almost nothing for them so that's fine
yeah because of other kills or nothing
from it
one day I saw me
a lot of confidence
the smokes live grenades all but forest
holding the ball can naked it's one more
kill he's gonna be able to do it a
ridiculous quad kill to save the round
we're gonna see this Hill classic we
haven't seen this clip Minh Henry Club
it if you go to clip it boys if it comes
in you've got a common quality finally
makes it work cold there's peaks around
the clock it never runs best friend
today and look at this the old coming
wave the cold fear huh
he takes for this was a cheese round he
manages to get three killed on the
retake that was absolutely massive the
diffuse as well and he's played getting
it done he's praised him there for an
ace can you say that's insane
Georgia gets the eat no with that it's
gonna get them it looks like it's a done
deal
nitro has not turned up in this final
map and as trolleys are so close to this
point what guiltiness Sakura and that's
it the grand slam is there's ESL pro
league season eight
Oh Matthew can you believe it the first
map it looked like they were out of it
they weren't turning up that key plants
weren't there but they adapted and
that's why they're considered the
world's best right now to be honest
Henry absolutely candy anticipation was
a fish was always theirs they were the
heavy favorite coming in and they show
off why from the middle of April to now
they've been absolutely dominant liquid
needs and perhaps the best run they ever
have and they still come up shy they hit
double digits every single chance
but a shoreless on top of the world
forget the stars they are the stars they
are the atmosphere they are everything
in between liquid trump by plasma
back-to-back ETS back to Mac Pro League
marsai season seven Chicago and now for
the first time
the first time in history the vegetable
[ __ ] die hey tell Grand Slam it
destroy all guys that was it that was
2018 I'm gonna be honest with you it was
a pretty sick year and I don't think
2019 can hold a candle to it but I guess
time will tell now this is gonna sound
kind of corny but my favorite part of
the year was seeing how you guys
interact with our content so keep
dropping those likes keep leaving those
comments into 2019 and speaking of let
me know what your favorite moment from
2018 was in the comments section of this
video and I'll see you next year
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button